you
do you think that once you began to
recognize that injustice that
humiliation you began to sort of piece
together a more three-dimensional
picture of black South Africans as
opposed to the many South Africans who
either supported or ignored apartheid
who who never really let black people
come into focus as as real people to
them yes but I think you have to look at
the circumstances it was unthinkable for
me to meet or know deaf people who would
share my interests with whom in other
words there could be some sort of
natural rapport and meeting if he's
always on the the the servant master
basis and even if you were the child of
the master and mistress you still had
this this particular position but being
troubled about it and beginning great
readers I always was beginning to find
out that there were that there's
something called racism that existed in
the world and I was living in it I was
part of it and then when when I was
older and we're very briefly to took the
train every day in which to the
University and there for the first time
I met even then there were one or two
there were a few young blacks remember
the University of course was white only
but they were certain certain courses
that were not available in the black
universities and then as a concession at
graduate level postgraduate level few
backs would come in and so I met one or
two black people with whom I had far
more in common then I had was the young
White's that I knew in the in the town I
was not interested I wasn't sporty many
of the things that they did were of no
him not particularly interested to me
and here were young people black who
were trying to write who were beginning
to write so we have this enormous not
just ambition we had this enormous way
approach to life and the mystery of life
and social questions in our lives and
then I began at that age to make black
friends and then as I myself became a
young published writer then I'm and I
moved into a different circle which was
again journalists actors people who are
- normally indeed don't follow the the
rules the conservative rules and where
the feeling about the incredible
distortions of racism not only the
oppression of blacks but the distortions
in your personality in your mind as
white these we can be much thought of my
life
and indeed started my way to freedom
from racism from racist ideas that I've
been inculcated at school at home
everywhere since childhood